MARY RADOMILE: Welcome to
Google Developers Live.
My name is Mary Radomile.
I'm here with the Google
Open Source Programs Office.
And today we are meeting
with Ian McDonald, who
is going to tell us a little
bit about his experience
with Google Summer
of Code as a student.
Welcome Ian.
IAN MCDONALD: Thank you.
MARY RADOMILE: Can you tell
us a little bit about yourself
and the project
that you worked on?
IAN MCDONALD: Yeah, so, like you
said, my name is Ian MacDonald.
I'm a software engineer
here at Google now.
And I graduated from
McGill University.
The organization I work
with is called Kernel.org,
which is the Linux
Kernel Archive.
MARY RADOMILE: So tell us how
you got involved with GSOC.
IAN MCDONALD: So when I was
looking for jobs one summer
I went on Google and searched
"software engineering jobs,"
and managed to find the
Summer of Code website.
And I sort of went
through all the materials
and figured out what
it was all about,
and submitted a
few applications,
and was accepted
to be a student.
MARY RADOMILE: Great.
Now tell us a little bit about
the application process itself.
How long did that take you?
Was it difficult?
IAN MCDONALD: So the application
process for Summer of Code
is different from a lot
of other internships.
It's very collaborative
between student and mentor.
So you can submit your
application many times
beforehand and get
feedback from mentors,
which I think makes the
applications stronger,
and let's you meet your
mentors beforehand, get
to know them a
little bit better,
decide if it's someone you
want to work with for a summer.
And it also lets
you get feedback
from the people who are
going to be reviewing
the application, which
I think is very helpful.
MARY RADOMILE: Absolutely.
And you said that you ended
up working with Kernel--
IAN MCDONALD: Kernel.org.
Yeah.
MARY RADOMILE: Kernel.org
Tell us about the project
that you worked on.
IAN MCDONALD: So I
worked on a project which
was focused on
analyzing HTTP access
logs across many
different machines
and centralizing them into
one location where we could
do real time analysis on them,
and also look back at graphs
for things like answer
questions about who's accessing
the website, what sort of
things were they doing,
what does the traffic
look like there?
MARY RADOMILE: Right.
Very cool.
And what about like a typical
day as a GSOC student?
What is it like for you?
IAN MCDONALD: So it's pretty
flexible, which is nice.
I'm a bit of a late riser,
and so I would usually
work a few hours in the
morning, a few in the afternoon,
and then later at
night a bit more.
And it's nice to have time off
in the afternoon to sort of go
and exercise is
what I like to do.
And then I would usually
work a little bit
later into the night
just because it's quieter
and that's when I
can focus better.
MARY RADOMILE: OK, great.
How did you interact
with the organization
that you worked
with, and how often?
Were they in different
time zones or what
was your standard
mode of communication?
IAN MCDONALD: So we were
usually communicating
using a program called IRC,
which is Internet Relay Chat,
and there were three other
people who I was really
working closely
with as a student.
And one of them lived
in the Netherlands
actually, which was a
little bit inconvenient.
We would have to talk a little
bit in the morning more.
But the other two
were in North America,
not in the same time zone.
And there are pretty responsive.
Usually if I sent
a message to them
I would get a response
within 30 minutes or so.
MARY RADOMILE: That's great.
Now, what about your project
by the end of the term?
Are you still working
with the organization now?
How have you been
involved going forward?
IAN MCDONALD: So I'm not as
involved now as I was certainly
when I was a student.
But I did do a
bit of work on it.
I participated in Summer of
Code as a student two times
and then as a mentor once.
MARY RADOMILE: Wonderful.
IAN MCDONALD: And
I did a bit of work
on it in the school years
between when I was a student.
So you know I was still involved
a little bit, and obviously
enough to be a mentor at
the end of all of that.
MARY RADOMILE: Great.
That's wonderful.
Now finally, is there
any gotchas or things
that you'd recommend
for other students who
are applying to be in
Google Summer of Code,
and any tips or tricks
that you can provide?
IAN MCDONALD: Yeah,
so I guess the one
tip I would have is
to get involved early.
Because especially
when I was a mentor,
and you see the applications
and the students who
are sort of engaged
from the beginning,
and asking questions, and trying
to learn about the project,
and also getting
feedback from mentors,
those are the applications
which are stronger.
MARY RADOMILE: OK, great.
Well, thank you so much.
And thank you all for
coming and listening today.
My name is Mary
Radomile and I'm here
with Open Source
Programs Office.
We'll see you next time.